I just crowd-sourced my questions from
real children nice just straight from
the mouths of babes
so who's six wants to know de storks
like to have parties and do they like
chocolate cake absolutely historic slub
to have parties chocolate cake is their
favorite dessert
right after worms she also would like to
know do they like to go on boogie boards
I feel like it might be hard for them to
go in flippers a little bit that's it
because of their like talent yeah and
their wings might not be able to grab
it's a boogie board I think they're okay
but I don't think they can surf Ella
who's 11 saw the trailer and she said it
it looks complicated what is this movie
about that's pretty funny what's it
about well it's about love I think on
some level you know good overcoming evil
discovering your your destiny finding
out that you're up something you didn't
have in the beginning of the movie that
you know ends up being yours one of your
saving graces it's lovely
Coco who's ten would like to know would
you rather go skydiving or dive in with
sharks
I would like to skydive with a diving
suit on and so over the ocean and then
when I hit the ocean I go straight down
and grab the oxygen mask and be
surrounded by sharks like the greatest
dancer of all time thank you were you
concerned at all about opening up a big
can of worms for parents out there
regarding the talk this is a good way to
avoid the awkward conversation yeah just
say like use it's essentially a
documentary yeah yeah yeah where did I
come from
let's just go see stories yeah yeah
let's watch sorts again can we listen
again until you get it finally accept
the truth there's one less baby to
deliver
you